all right hearties it feels so good to
say that word hearties yet again because
tis the season season nine of when calls
the heart is about to kick off so to
celebrate we're gonna welcome you on in
get comfortable you guys know these
familiar faces we're gonna do a live
event celebrating season nine of when
calls the heart of course i'm deidre
bejar from entertainment tonight and it
is such an honor for me to be here with
some of my favorite humans on the planet
some of the cast of when calls the heart
so please help me welcome erin krakow
we've got jack wagner
pascal hutton
andrea brooks
evan smith
and freshly shaven uh chris mcnally are
we not can we talk everyone's been quiet
hi
i want to applaud for everybody i think
it is so nice to see your faces of
course we are going to talk all things
season 9 of when calls the heart ahead
of the big season 9 premiere this sunday
march 6 8 p.m on hallmark channel but
first just like chris you just said you
wanted to talk and say hi how's everyone
feeling
well i just noticed everyone was kind of
miming and i wasn't sure if we were
supposed to do that
you didn't get that you didn't get the
memo we were not supposed to talk no no
no it's a mind beginning
i'm looking forward to a mimed interview
and i think it would be easier for me
you do well in a mind interview
hearties i hope you're taking gifts of
all of that beautiful miming work that
we just saw here
um i don't want to waste it
i don't want to waste another minute i
want to get right into it you know
season nine to build up the anticipation
it's just it's so exciting um aaron and
chris my first couple questions are
going to be for the two of you you know
season eight ended on such a high note
we have elizabeth and lucas together we
had that huge moment on the bridge the
huge celebration in the library where
are things aaron going to pick up when
season 9 starts as this courtship starts
to really blossom and
unfold well it isn't immediately
following our season eight finale but
it's not too far after so
time in hope valley is a little fluid
but we'll say this is like a couple
months after season eight ended
elizabeth has gone to hamilton she's
coming back to hope valley and there's
like a very
loving lovely reunion with lucas
um and things are just in a really good
promising place they're excited to spend
more time together as a couple
and and chris how are you feeling now
that you know the secret is out there in
the world we know that elizabeth and
lucas are together and and they're gonna
you know go on this this romantic
journey in season nine how are you
feeling
i'm excited to watch it because i uh as
always i don't remember exactly what we
did so i kind of
follow along like this
i like this show
you like the show that's a good sign
you know i think a big tenant of of
lucas bouchard culture is the grand
gesture we've seen so many of them and
in some of the teases that we've seen
leading up to season nine you know
there's this hot air balloon moment that
looks pretty major um erin can you tell
me like are grand gestures going to
continue throughout season nine are we
gonna continue seeing like big public
displays of affection between the two
i mean there are some but i think this
season more than ever elizabeth is
trying to impart on lucas the importance
of the little things and the little
moments and that sometimes those are
just as magical as the grand romantic
gestures so we're gonna find a lot of
uh sweet moments this season in the
little things
okay now chris how does how does lucas
feel about being told to i don't know it
sounds like he's being told to reel it
in a bit maybe
frame his approach to romance here
i think that we all
can uh can learn and evolve in our lives
so if lucas needs to
learn that not all gestures need to be
grand i think that's something he can
tackle and approach
well look i i don't want to get too
ahead of myself
but i'm such a sucker for romance and
i'm really a sucker for elizabeth's
happiness at the end of the day
and seeing how happy
she is at the end of season eight and
and obviously leading through season
nine i mean are we gonna exchange i love
yous could there be a proposal in season
nine
ah
anything is possible in hope valley
um
certainly wouldn't want to give any of
that away but yeah
but yeah anything is anything is
possible in hope ballet there's always a
bit of romantic magic so you have to
stay tuned
chris let me ask you i know you
obviously can't tell us any explicit
details but like are they on the track
towards a pretty serious romance here
that could end in a proposal
[Laughter]
well
trying my best to remember he thought he
was squirming earlier i don't know
yeah i mean i i think that
this presents an opportunity for
elizabeth and lucas to
really truly court and get to know one
another because
in the previous seasons we've seen a
triangle happening and so it wasn't
um you know a concrete thing and so
once we've established that and then
yeah they start to explore it in in nine
and um
yeah to be honest i can't remember what
the question was
by the way you got you mentioned the
triangle and i feel like i need to say
because i'm sure there are people
watching like where's kevin so kevin
sent this picture he's busy
somewhere snowy
but
he's gonna do one of these interviews
with you soon i'm sure
yes yes that's it that's actually a
great thing to announce that plenty of
your your favorite faces you know that
you're already familiar with on one
calls the heart and also some new faces
that are coming to hope valley we'll be
doing multiple conversations throughout
the season um leading up to the sure to
be epic season nine finale so everybody
stay tuned for that um i mean chris i'll
just i'll leave you one more time ours a
little bit lucas
on the track
to getting real serious with their
romance it's all coming back to me now
yeah
is there a proposal
well i can't say one way or another um
however uh they they
there's some there's some exploring some
learning and um
and some pushing of boundaries perhaps
and uh
and getting down to
brass tacks
he forgot the question again obviously
i was going to say pascal i really
appreciate the assist there i know that
you're a journalist too rosemary is
running the valley boys and she's a
woman chasing a story much like i am
yeah we needed to try and get him back
on track
he eluded us once again but yeah yeah
romance like getting down to brass tacks
well we will stay tuned erin it's
hilarious you you show us that wonderful
photo of kevin mcgarry who we all love
and adore so much
um
it's a beautiful segue into talking a
little bit about nathan you know
obviously there's so many um fans who
are concerned with his happiness and
want to see him thriving in season nine
how are things gonna pick up when when
nathan you know really kind of
encounters lucas and elizabeth as a
couple
well it's a really interesting dynamic
to see these friendships kind of grow
they might start a bit awkward at the
beginning of season nine but i actually
really love the friendship that
elizabeth and nathan are are working on
and that lucas and nathan are working on
and i think you'll find that like anyone
who was or is team nathan there are a
lot of fantastic stories that kevin is
going to get to play this season
really fun stuff and the best way you
can support your favorite character is
by watching him
team hope valley team hopefully
uh chris how do you feel about lucas and
nathan's i don't know friendship bond is
it a friendship at this point how are
they going into season nine
i wouldn't say that they're friends off
off the top but
they um
they have kind of a brotherly
relationship where you don't always get
along but there's something
something there
and so they actually have a fun journey
this season and i enjoyed
working with kevin
um
i like where they where they leave off i
feel like there's there's the
possibility you know they're not
by any means best friends this season uh
but we get to enter a new phase of this
dynamic that we haven't seen before
all right room to grow
and uh and i i'm really keeping my
fingers crossed that we're gonna get to
see a lot of little jack this season
he's just such a cutie that highland
goodrich and seeing the small clips that
i have so far
what is in store for little jack this
season and and how much are we gonna see
of little jack elizabeth and lucas
together
we're so excited that highland joined us
this season he's really something
special i think the hearties are going
to love him and
and we got to do a lot more scenes with
little jack especially i mean chris can
speak to this lucas and little jacket to
spend some real bonding time together
and it's super heartwarming for
elizabeth
but um really fun to get to have that
family time
yeah chris do you think lucas is really
leaning into the you know
without disrespecting his father but
really kind of stepping up and being a
father figure to little jack
very much so yeah
uh i think that lucas
might see a lot of himself in little
jack
and
they he doesn't want to overstep any
lines and um
you know
take over any kind of job but so he's
gradually sort of building that
relationship and and building that trust
and seeing where it is or where it goes
um but he
has so much love for little jack and we
had
many many opportunities to explore that
this season and highland who plays
little jack now is phenomenal he's uh
he's just a great a great spirit with a
really infectious kind of energy and
laugh
and so we had an awesome time
amazing well i can't wait to see all of
that unfold
speaking of of amazing energy i
immediately think of rosemary and lee um
kevin and pascal i want to go to the two
of you uh it has been something quite
seeing rosemary and lee you know not
only their their their beautiful romance
and marriage but really leaning into
their careers um we already we already
get a little hat tip to the valley voice
one of my favorite publications
uh and we know
we know kevin that lee is is stepping up
and and he he wants to be the mayor of
hope valley so pascal why don't we start
with you tell me a little bit about
where we find rosemary in season nine is
she like really a woman on a mission
yes is she ever not a woman yeah no that
is so true yeah just plug in a new
mission and she's ready to go
but yes she's very revved up she's very
revved up at the beginning of the season
she's
got a mission she's
she's got a direction and a focus and
she is undeterred and so i mean i don't
know i feel like you really can plug
those descriptors into any season for
rosemary but i really do feel like she's
fired up at the beginning of this season
and of course she's taken over
lee's office and kind of like moved into
the space and so
that's been a lot of fun that was a lot
of fun for the two of us to play with
and what does that do to a marriage
when you're living together and working
together in such close proximity all the
time like when do you when do you get a
break
my wife is working from the house right
now and i was asking for her to spend
more time at home for years
and now i can't get rid of her
she's
always here
always
i actually had to say something other
than my khan i love you you go back to
the office for a little while what
happened my goodness
i felt bad but i think it was healthy
for the marriage
okay let's let's go back to rosemary and
lee i'm curious spending so much time
not only married but but working
together uh what kind of an impact does
that have on their marriage for better
or for worse kevin
well i think that for the two of them
it's it's ideal because you get conflict
they're in each other's space all the
time she has such a big personality
she's always in his space and i think we
much like anybody else requires a little
space for himself so it's great for
actors it's so much fun for us to play
that because we can just we're annoyed
with each other all the time and then
there's all the love on the other side
so it really this year i think just in
each other's space all the time her
forcing him to do stuff he doesn't want
it to do it it really gave us a lot of
opportunities to do sort of the stuff
that we enjoy doing most with these
characters
yeah so it was there was lots of that
kind of opportunity
pascal i have to tell you i think it's
so wonderful that it to me it feels like
rosemary's really found her footing like
we've seen her do a couple different
things over the years but like it feels
like the valley voice has just ignited a
real passion out of her is there like a
story she's really chasing this season
or
how are we gonna see her her passion for
her career really unfold
i think uh
yes that there are stories that she is
like hunting down throughout the season
but i also think you see her how does
she
she's obviously
personally
entangled
with everyone in the town and so how
does she remain unbiased and
reporting in a neutral fashion
without having a hidden agenda based on
her personal relationships with people
and you see her kind of stumble and
bumble along as she
figures that out all this season and and
the strain that that might cause various
relationships throughout the season
which i thought was i thought that was
very interesting
um to see that happen because we haven't
seen that before with rosemary and um
yeah i mean she's she's
hunting down the stories and they
changed throughout the season to kind of
push the story along but uh you know
she's nosy
she's got a nose for news i love it
and and i'd be remiss to just sit here
and not bring this up and kevin and
pascal we have joked in the past that i
feel so terrible that i keep asking you
guys this question but i'm hoping that
we'll get some resolution in season nine
you know fans really love rosemary they
really love lee and i think they would
really love to see them as parents um
however that story comes about
not our business but i think fans
nonetheless would love to see them as
mom and dad
can you tease if we're gonna get some
sort of closure or resolution to that
question this season
well we've been asked that question
so many times and by you also so many
times and we've given so many answers to
that question in an attempt to try and
appease people but
i don't what do we say this time like
how do we what do we say that's that's
concrete and reliable this time without
any kind of tea
i really think what i would say is i
really think fans just need to
come along and go for the ride with the
coulters
this season
um
it's gonna take you on lots of twists
and turns and they're gonna be
unexpected and
uh
i think that's the best way we can
answer that is uh
that's it that's it i'll go i'll go one
further than that i'd say that at the
end of the season both pascal and i are
happy with where the characters are
going
we're quite content with the storyline
for
rosie and lee
okay well whatever that means i i guess
i'm happy if they're happy um and i do
hope that we get some sort of closure to
that storyline because again i don't
want to have to ask you this when we're
here next year promoting season 10.
i i agree
my final question for kevin and pascal
um you know as as two actors who have
played a couple who is so steady in
their marriage for seasons i'm curious
if you have advice
for a new couple on the show obviously
elizabeth and lucas what would rosemary
and lee's advice be to this new couple
as they're sort of on their journey to
to finding um i don't know eternal bliss
like you two have found character
something about um
definitely breath back
yeah just get down to the brass tacks
yeah
guys
don't listen to anybody don't listen to
anybody's advice
certainly not liam rosemary they've been
known to give bad advice over and over
again so
go to go to somebody else for advice
i would say the advice that lee and
rosemary have to give
probably doesn't fit the mold of any
other relationship
exactly
it works for them but i don't think it's
a normal relationship that way but you
know what i think it was rosemary and
correct me if i'm wrong because this was
a minute ago but i think it was rosemary
who encouraged elizabeth to accept
lucas's invitation to go to union city
to that book reading event so
maybe that set us on the right path
great
happy
aaron was that the virginia wolf reading
is that the one you're referring to yes
good memory oh i've been brushing up on
my one calls the heart clips as we as we
get closer to season nine and yes i do
believe that was rosemary and i
appreciate that she leaned into her got
instinct and obviously paid off i think
that that's sweet i think i was really
just excited to pick out your outfits
for that trip
that's why she was really pushing for
that
let's get the outfits going
um well andrea i want to pivot over to
you hi how are you i'm well how are you
i'm wonderful thank you
um you know i i don't i don't want to
start off on a on a bummer note but you
know i really felt for faith in the
season eight finale that stagecoach
pushes away and and faith kind of says
to fiona like part of me was really
hoping that that carson would still be
standing there so
is our girl heartbroken going into
season nine like how's faith doing
whoo
that was a tough scene i think right up
until that bitter last moment faith
wasn't sure if carson would actually be
getting on the stage coach or not so
when pulled away she was half expecting
him to maybe still be there
but no these characters have different
journeys they need to separate they need
to follow their hearts right now
obviously faith's heart is telling her
to be in hope valley where she loves
working where she loves providing
medical assistance for everybody in the
community and carson has to go off do
his thing
surgical skills have to be honed in on
um so yeah they're they're separating
it's good um
but yeah there's some there's some
heartache that has to be contended with
at the same time and of course faith
isn't really a character that's
generally good at dealing with her own
feelings she tends to bottle things up
quite a bit so
yeah we're going to see that play out
especially at the beginning of the ninth
season
i mean how is she navigating all of that
the the inheritance of running the
infirmary all by herself and then also
having to deal with you know all these
like really complicated emotions
yeah i mean i think it is a bit of a
shock she is standing on her own two
feet she's the sole doctor in town of
course she has molly by her side and
she's wonderful but there's a lot
writing on her shoulders this year she's
got a lot to prove and of course she
also wants to make sure that the
infirmary doesn't fall behind
technologically speaking so she's a
she's a hard-working girl she was known
as a nurse in town and now she wants to
prove herself as the doctor so yes a lot
going on career-wise um but will she be
able to open up her heart again i don't
know it's i'd never say never kind of
like aaron said
ah
that was my next question i mean do you
think it's a priority for for faith to
you know kind of pick up the the pieces
from where she ended season eight and
maybe find new love in season nine
i do think it's
absolutely a possibility um i think she
would be receptive to that idea but
again she's pushing everything off to
the side and she's focusing on the
doctor stuff at the moment but yeah is
she a character who kind of needs that
in her life i would argue probably
but
what'd you say
i said give it the track record even
though
rocky crap
uh like sparks of romance there have
been some moments she's had some moments
um
yeah but i think i i do love that this
character is career focused i love that
she loves helping people but yeah the
fact that she represses a lot it's fun
to play there are some fun moments where
things bubble to the surface and she has
to contend with those those feelings so
yeah it's fun
well listen i i
love following along on social media
with the hearties and i try to you know
tune into what they're chattering
whispering about and after the season
eight finale faith and nathan have a
really lovely scene together where she's
you know tending to his hand
a lot of hearties were kind of
intimating like this could be a really
cool um have you seen those
conversations and what do you think is
that a possibility
yeah i saw i saw those conversations i
remember when we were filming that scene
thinking that people could potentially
read into it the way that i guess they
did
but i actually think that was just a
nice tender hearted scene between two
people who've gone through something
quite similar and they're both mending
broken hearts so i just thought it was a
nice little check in with one another
and that's kind of what this show is all
about just standing by your fellow
citizens being there extending a hand a
helping hand would need be or in his
case a wounded hand um and we're so good
what a sound bite andrea the wounded
hand yeah
you want to answer my questions from now
on yeah
well i just need to make sure i include
brass tacks in here
[Laughter]
hearts call and there's a lot of brass
tacks this season
beautiful i guess my final question i
mean are we gonna see at least faith and
nathan maybe developing their friendship
more shared scenes in season nine
well i mean there's a lot of potential
for crossover between an overlap
storyline wise between these characters
they're both they're first responders
they always put others needs ahead of
their own and they both confront danger
on a daily basis in different ways so
absolutely there's some room for overlap
and growth um and i think they're two
characters that do as i've said
they have a bit of a similar history
with their
with their with their emotions their
feelings their hearts so yeah there's
always the potential
my goodness okay we'll have to stay
tuned i can't wait to see what happens
because i'm always rooting for faith and
her happiness
thank you
of course
and uh and i want to go over to judge
bill avery jack wagner
yes hi how are you doing
i love all the questions first of all
all the questions that you've asked that
you kind of asked the beginning every
year that's what i love about this show
is because as i hear you ask the
questions
i know i can tell you that the onion
gets peeled back
on all of these questions for every
character and every couple and
you know you're spot on with your
questions i can just tell the audience
i'll speak for everybody that they get
peeled back beautifully this year and by
the end of the season there's this real
you know resolution to the obstacles
that all these characters face
so
well
that is so wonderful to hear because i i
truly you know it's such a joy covering
this show and i love being on the
precipice of a season and then you know
season five i'm like oh my gosh that
just happened we sort of hinted to that
and then you know by the time it's the
season finale it's like oh my gosh you
guys just blew the lid off and i will
ask you about the season finale but but
jack i want to i want to pivot back to
you um bill avery he's always got you
know his hand in a million different
things and i i believe he's he's
considering running for mayor is that
right like where do we find him in
season nine
yeah we pick it up right there right in
this mayor race and uh and
you know that's
that was the fun part of for this uh you
know this arc of this beginning of the
year was was actually
working with kevin uh as two guys that
are you know kind of like a little
disgruntled in how things are going you
know and chromogeny and you know that's
kind of the fun part of these characters
and you know how it all unfolds you know
we we get to
sit in our curmudgeonness if that's a
word so yeah
well if rosemary's got a nose for news i
feel like um bill has a real sensibility
when it comes to trouble coming to town
he knows how to sniff out the bad guys
and um and he knows how to like
handle business if if that sort of makes
sense is he gonna be dealing with some
complicated matters this season as you
know
different um broody characters come in
and out of town
yeah 100
you know and that's that's this has
really been a really nice year for me as
an actor because i've you know had a lot
of diversified story lines you know i'm
really really glad about that i got to
work actually with andrea faith we did
some stuff and we were able to find some
comedy and some pretty serious
you know uh dialogue and and
situations and um jumped in with with
kevin and pascal you know and
trying to solve a crime and how you
bring the newspaper in and everybody
wants to get involved but you know that
that's the the part of being the judge
and former sheriff and coming from the
mounties is you know he's a structured
sort of disciplinarian by the book black
and white thinker but the real fun part
for me is humanizing him through all of
the the problems he faces and how he
deals with them right so you know that's
where the comedy comes in in the fun
part of the show and i think and also
you know sort of the loving part of this
character that you know we didn't really
understand when he first came on
and when bill is not out there you know
handling business and making sure that
everybody in hope valley is safe you
know there have been some wonderful bill
moments over the years where we really
see his softer and his his tender side
whether it's you know
being um with with molly his blossoming
romance with molly that i thought was
maybe gonna take off or uh little
moments with little jack can you tease
like what's in store for for bill's
personal life in season nine
uh you know
it's just like bill's busy you know
bill's busy that's about you know he's
just busy
he's he's busy getting his nose and
everybody's business and trying to you
know be the patriarch of this town and
clean up messes and you know assert
himself but i think uh to speak to that
aaron and i had a scene towards the end
of the year that i we had a very
unexpected
you know emotional scene it really
wasn't written that way but that's how
it unfolded and baby jack was part of
that and it seems like for the past few
seasons that's always been
uh you know there's been that one scene
with elizabeth and bill that have really
been heart wrenching and you know we had
another one this year i would say
wouldn't you aaron
i would absolutely say that and it it
snuck up on me i wasn't expecting it and
and actually like
it's always so lovely when someone
you've been working with for a long time
surprises you and i i find that
constantly with our cast but in this
scene in particular i feel like
jack just showed up and like bared his
soul in a way that immediately
q water works i was just really affected
by what he brought to set that day it
was really very vulnerable and i i
yeah our viewers are really going to
appreciate that i think
oh thank you same to you it was uh you
know it's such a give and take and as
aaron spoke to the entire cast it's
you know i've been around longer than
anybody i'm the oldest and you know this
this cast is is really special you know
everybody is collaborative the egos are
all in check clearly except for kevin
and um
you know so i uh it's just such a you
know we really do
like get along and like each other and
work hard at making this a
a very very feel-good show as well as a
dramatic show and a romantic show and a
fun funny show
well i i have no doubt that season nine
is absolutely just going to set the bar
um in terms of giving us all the feels
and also all the romance and and all
those just moments that we we come back
to when calls the heart force season
after season and with that
just teased a moment that sounds so um
tender and emotional that is not to be
missed and i want to go around to
everybody and i would love to know if
you can tease
one moment in season nine that you're so
most excited for the hearties to see
erin let's start with you oh
one moment it's so hard to narrow down
um
really
this is a tough one um
i have a scene with
pascal
that is a personal favorite of mine this
season and i'm trying to think what i
can say
other than
uh
it's just a really beautiful loving
supportive scene that um celebrates
female friendship and
um their history together and i just
i love pascal obviously and i love the
relationship that elizabeth and rosemary
has together that they have together and
i'm just really excited for people to
see that scene
pascal you know exactly the scene that
aaron's referring to
well for a while there i was a bit i was
a bit confused i'll be honest i was like
which one is it we've had we had so many
scenes yes okay
i knew i know i know which one she's
talking about and yes it it was i mean
it is and it was a
really special to film and it is a
special scene and i can't wait for
people to see it
okay is there one separate from that
that you are most excited for fans to
see
yeah there's a scene uh i think it's in
the i think it's in the finale and i
just think it's a scene with so much
overflowing joy and exuberance i just
i think all the parties will like leap
out of their seats when they see it and
they'll be like jumping up and down so
excited and so i'm very excited for that
scene
and is that a lean rosemary moment
well you'll have to wait
okay okay good tease uh kevin do you
have any idea what pascal is referring
to there or do you have a favorite scene
that stands out
well i think i know the one she's
talking about and if we're on the same
page that's that's my choice too by far
it's uh
it's a very
uh
joyful moment that's it's kind of
unbridled and raw and fun
so
i i hope people
stick around and enjoy that one i think
uh
it was so much fun to do
and uh
i think people are gonna love it
oh my gosh okay andrea brooks favorite
moment you're most excited for the
hearties to see it's so hard to pick um
i'll probably give you the wrong answer
first of all i do i love the group
scenes i always say this but there are
some
positive moments that include everyone
this year that are always personal
favorites of mine but there's one um
season that i also think is in the
finale for faith where she's overwhelmed
with
with
a number of things she's got a lot on
her mind and she just has this kind of
brutally honest conversation with
another character
and um
it ended up being kind of meaningful and
interesting and kind of a nice way to
cap off the season so so yeah i'd say
there's a an emotional moment for faith
coming up okay and you said finale
in the finale yeah wow this finale
finale is just
full
okay chris
well uh lucas decides to do ned's taxes
this year
yeah yeah you just go through our
country and it's it's actually riveting
you'd think it's not but it's great so
that's one but another one i'll toss out
there
um that doesn't happen by the way i'm
sure
um
uh there's a scene with
lucas and um
and little jack that i really like
possibly some other people um but uh i
think
you it's just really sweet i don't want
to give too much away about it but um
lucas and and little jack end up in a i
think a place of kind of like
good buddies
and uh and lucas kind of leans on little
jack in a way and uh he comes through
for him and i just think it's very very
tender and endearing so
i'd say that's my favorite um but then
there's also this really great scene i'm
just gonna add another one three one of
them was fake two um
where
[Music]
lucas and nathan get to have some fun
together and be a bit competitive with
one another in a non
non-suitor type fashion they're not uh
vying for elizabeth anymore but they
still get to exercise that that
competitive thread and um
one of them will have to
lick their wounds but it ends up being
in a very uh sweet sweet matter and i'm
i'm happy that it plays out the way that
it does
oh my god that was such a solid tease
chris we got so many moments there to
look forward to
thank you
and uh and jack will end with you is
there one moment in season nine that
you're just so delighted to share with
the hardys
well other than what i spoke to the
scene with uh aaron and bill and
elizabeth but bill beats up a younger
dude
yes
i love winning fights on television
tell me more what happened
listen i'm not gonna get into detail
okay
just don't mess with judge bill avery
okay
kapow i want a t-shirt that says that
don't mess with bill avery
kapow kapow right all right
look this was made up
before we say goodbye any message to the
hearties you know as we go into season
nine
everybody
i'll start with
a big huge
load of gratitude from me okay that's as
far as i can go blessings to all and
thank you so much for the love and
support for for this show and us as
actors
lovely yeah i i echo that and i would
also say that like
you know
we really do get along so well and we
love this show and we love getting to
tell these stories and
and the reason we get to keep coming
back year after year is because the
hearties continue supporting us so
i hope that they will come along for the
journey of season nine
and tell their friends and keep watching
because we'd all really love to be back
for a season 10.
right i think right but we all looked
at that yes 100
i think i have joked individually with
every single one of you that i am
ex-fully expecting one calls the heart
season 75. i need to show you
becoming grandparents you know just like
a million people running in hope valley
um this show is just magic it truly is
and i for one am so grateful that you
guys are giving us such a rich and
fulfilling season nine hearties you
cannot miss it this sunday march 6 8 p.m
hallmark channel i will be tweeting
along hashtag hardy's well we'll will
you guys
yeah oh absolutely
for sure yeah deidra big thank you for
your investment in this show and knowing
it so well it makes interviewing like
unbelievably comfortable and really
great thank you oh my gosh it's my
pleasure truly you guys are just like i
said before you guys are a magical group
and you deliver so many incredible
moments on television so sunday
everybody do not miss it hashtag
hearties thank you all so much thanks
guys thanks watching you thank you hi
thanks hardy's everybody thank you bye
guys bye
[Music]
you